sumit on that plate both guys were
determined to get a play for their team
hardly
[Applause]
[Music]
there's these eight second-chance points
six offensive rebounds jam-packed the
story tables step-back three hearts down
another one three of six pardon against
Jetson six to shoot
pardon got to the rim kept by the rookie
good Robinson was a great shot blocker
[Applause]
step back
[Applause]
[Music]
dancing again
that's fear in a lot of people's hearts
he's in an open court with the
basketball same for this guy's step back
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
shot clock at four seconds down to three
hardin puts it up in hitch
I mean it's like money on our fares only
food man she was so much fun to work
with it's terrific Oh put on a free talk
about terrific that's James Harden
starters with 10 apiece Richardson and
Tyler Johnson the lead for the Rockets
was it 16 but at halftime it's a 5-point
game on TNT this is really good job with
defensive transition by Miami forcing
it's the half was hard a half-court and
on target to load up on this side as
hardness takes it down the middle puts
it up and and what a move by Harden he
went right into the teeth of the defense
watch this tough drive to as James just
powers through the contacts ooh just a
great finish by a great player back
outside to are down six down the
Artie
Danny's team forgot that point but he
improved so quickly in the disk f
improving there it is hand of the cookie
jar bucket for Harden and one shrewder
picking up the foul
if you reach on James Harden it's a
problem as soon as your arm is extended
in that position you are inviting him to
do this
[Applause]
[Music]
are trying to drive got passed George
water is gone and the latest back to
four
[Music]
he could do it on
that's what you call behind the back
crossover step back
[Music]
[Applause]
Kyrie Irving tried to come over for the
block you got the whole team trying to
stop in the minute he gets that
space-hardened that he wants he's gonna
attack you and finish so strong kick to
the line easy for him
Irving with who's so the rocket shoot
they've got a foul to give
and harden he takes the shot blocker out
puts it right into the body and he gets
it back he breaking it off and a step
back boy that's strong you got to really
be strong that deep 53:48 tries it again
James's eight points by heart
at 34 to 20 quarters and the Rockets let
her stop for a free throw or something
like that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just keep stepping around
here comes James Valley
step back
between the ears James Harden again
putting on a show a step back three to
tie the ballgame
pardon trying to get three down to three
down to territory
James Harden appointed for incredible
shot James Harden with two warriors that
drapes honest wise I'm going to get this
to go down and easily could have been
fouled in the grill of draymond Green a
former Defensive Player of the Year
Park the other way they're pecking away
at
step back
[Applause]
for mates out of 31 attempts coming into
this one
three tonight here's Hardin's if I
counted if it goes it does he else is
what to find the arms again it's kind of
an unnatural
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
man down and he fouled him
so harden drains the three and gets an
animal look at Chris Paul yard for 49%
and Denver's is 7 X 28 behind the arc
and they're starting to the basket
first two point bucket of the Knights
easy ones around the rim
arguing with a step-back three got
another one shaking his head
look at it Milwaukee's bench saying you
can't guard me now for the last seven in
a row for Houston how much you can do
against that there's again
rivers or no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they will tapping that up Oh we'll take
it in Washington rivers won't give it up
to heart
[Music]
turn all the way to the basket that was
a really good halftime Osmund Osmund is
going to hit him on top of the head
right there is he's laying it up in a
class everybody outlet so he could did
that's the number six
triple-double on the season for James
Harden up rewarding
[Applause]
[Music]
Aaron Gordon picks up part of this time
and he knocks down his first three of
the game see if there's another gear
tonight like there was last tonight
Martin's driving leaning and lunging it
in and a final on the magic boots does
not like the call let's see if we can
pick it up James harden on the drive
watch the little Euro step Tartars right
up in his jersey
and Hardin says no problem how about
that guy fine if you don't want to go to
the line
don't foul it you see Carter reach it in
right at the end then gets him on the
arm right there and James with great
spin on the ball
step back just like the dreamshade
James Harden step back it's on the shot
clock
harden steps back over Carruth Scottie
almost another man a little step back
created the separation and it rattles in
but it goes down bargain time again
takes it inside Rosa gets a basket
over gravity shorts used in energy
conservation mode now he's able to
create contact in the paper touch on the
rim but Rex you know what it's like to
play 42 to 45 minutes Stephenson gets
past rivers pass stolen by Hardin Arnie
time for the NBA in steals the crossover
at both ends of the floor and forces the
turnover and how about to kill it
crossover in transition I call that
blessing the Pope heart brings it back
out called wolf wolf gets right up it to
him harden the step-back the breeze
[Applause]
right now here's this myth work boss is
in it
harden is got a couple of triples well
points already on eight shots for James
Hart the league in scoring he'll dance
and just kill you with these triples
from outside and clutched onto inside by
PJ Tucker and 20 and 10 D in the Evan
I got the screenplay Pappy hammers it in
oh he's flying off the wing he had no
idea my switches again he's been
guarding them in a number of possessions
got to take away to the left hand oh
there he goes
drives past against each side
he finds that scene I Matador D is he
slices in that ball that Wahpeton Devon
Lane watching dribble so now are you in
trouble
usage this cockpit ball good job by
gardenin hearten one cider record at the
garden 61 point nurse talks about him
being a great new guy pardon right over
the top of green like he wasn't there 52
points per game overs last five he's got
18 with a defender in the Skrill now
it's hardens time hardest on the drive
slopes it up a tad that's the way
you play basketball in the 24-second
shot clock James
[Applause]
James Harden goes behind this screen by
Farid and knocks down his 37th point of
the night which is an average night for
James Harden we'll take it with five
seconds down to pour down to three punts
Tepes backfires
[Applause]
the core ability to turn it on when he
and look at the trying to cheat over on
him and he just steps back and fires
full force and that's the shot that he
can beat 80 double team with the step
back Krejci moment as james harden steps
back and delivers it pelicans at 7
colonel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the shots as touches this so feathery
really is hard endearing to the rain
finishes that 1:15 in the quarter for
the piping hot James Harden get downhill
as to there's really not much you can do
this oh [ __ ] thee nice little finish by
James Hart three points away he dances
back cakes and hits James Harden gets
his 30 points to extend the street to 25
straight named digs out the rebound
pulled team back on the shot clock it's
roll down to 9 now Korver shows palms
the shot is away in wood that's why it's
not fair just short the push off the
left arm push off and then he steps back
into his three harden the rebound
you can't put a hand on mr. Harden there
to step back free-throw line J good
starting forward that's a shot order the
foul watch harden just one on one and
even though you have good defense that's
step back it's just gross
barred by a couple of defenders all the
way to the rim thirty-eight Jake
suffered throughout his career he's got
eight rebounds parts on the truck look
what is what is what are they gonna do
when he's off balance and he just throws
it in like that how the glass will be
and here's the foul and that's going to
count three pointer and a chance for a
four-point play he's watching but bug he
thinks he's gotten a pretty good and the
step back in there as you see the
shooter always show and I'm enemy taking
forward and what the defender has to
keep in mind basket starts looking a
little smaller than they'd ever fuse
coming on their starting course James
Horton it's gonna make the comeback that
much more difficult
he is now scored 33 such a run breaker
here able to disc something the first
shot was a good one that was a cost
offensive trip by Westbrook Paul back
out harden for three standing offense
making plays again finding James Harden
Westbrook comes up to pick up Arden
Martin gets past him drives the floaters
open take the lead time turns the corner
and tell Steven Adams
mind your business big time play by a
big time plate not just lost the ball
against Chris almost got it and now he
does as he knocks it over the hardens
harden goes right back cleaver lays it
up in their biggest lead of the game
Chris Paul is three gives it up to James
James fires up agreed
[Applause]
history of gaming
he's look they're talking to his mom
that's who he's talking to you right
there
[ __ ] just raises up 25 feet
verse 17 to the my point line can you
imagine